[Music]
that is intriguing I'm just in what I'm
doing right now
[Music]
hey cash how much longer I got away for
my money God made this land for all of
us greedy people like you want to hog it
to yourself and your family and here my
family yeah
Cassius I'm your [ __ ] uncle I just
really need a job
telemarketing stick to the script hello
I'll just catch the screen sorry to
bother you I just wanted to make you
want to make some money here use your
white boys my white boards thank this
young man hey mr. Kramer
this is Langston from Riga love you was
that Visa or MasterCard
you're going upstairs my compadre okay
Bravo you don't have to sell out I'm not
selling out here's the starting salary
man I'm gonna have to get me some new
suits we will have a transformative
experience
[Music]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
I'm doing something I'm really good at
that's just the old you was way more
interested you are rolling with the big
dogs
greetings Cassius green I hope you did
not masturbate today we need you sharp
and ready to go
you